oh hello you guys guys so check it out
it's Coco fell asleep in the break room
so I put his hand in a bowl of warm
water come on man that's the stupidest
prank ever uh no it's the smartest
because it involves biology I bet it
worked already let's go check
Hitchcock no he's drowning he's
gonna take it back Jake Great Prank hey
Charles can we talk in the briefing room
for a second there's a question I gotta
ask you
it's happening Jake is gonna pop the
question he's gonna ask me to be his BM
no BM best man it's a common
abbreviation no one but you has ever
used it I am so relieved I thought maybe
he was gonna ask one of Amy's brothers
or Sarge hey man come on Charles
oh this is a lot to ask no it's not I
want to do it you want to cover my shift
this weekend so I can go to the White
Plains mall and meet Daryl strawberry at
the opening of a cell phone store
yes
that's exactly what I was hoping you'd
ask great thanks
you sure it's okay
very happy about it that'll be fun
that'll be fun uh look at my smile I
have to go now
oh my God Jake what do you say Bud will
you be my BM yes yes a million times yes
in your face Terry what I'm holding a
sparkler for you I hope to organize a
lot of this we could stick that sparkle
off your butt I'm the best man it's
Halloween
I'm surprised you didn't put on a
costume I was going to sir but then I
decided screw that jazz
well I'm the only one who ever dresses
up no one ever gets my costume and they
make fun of me so I'm done
these people don't deserve my dress-up
gifts
Charles
seriously no costume what the hell
Charles where's your Halloween spirit
you guys always make fun of me I have
never once insulted you in my life
especially vis-a-vis your appearance
yeah man we always love your costumes
remember last year when you came as that
person and or thing yes I do remember
sure permission is Sprint to my car get
my emergency costume does it matter if I
say no
[Music]
Bam Bam Boom
why are you dressed up you look like an
idiot but uh but yeah what are you
supposed to be a sassy car mechanic no
come on he's clearly the rejected
Pop-Tarts mascot Harry pop tart I'm not
you know who I am Squad that's enough
you're making boil for about on purpose
he's Elvis yes yes Elvis stoicho the
Canadian figure skater no
I'm so glad we could finally do this I
know Kylie says you're always stuck at
the precinct yeah
speaking of this is work sorry
what's up Rosa Captain called he needs
everybody back there's a lead on the
Nightingale Strangler we're looking for
a white male 510 medium build brown hair
small scar on his right cheek
okay his ammo is he finds lonely women
with no friends poisons their food and
then guts him in his van it's pretty
gnarly last scene wearing a salmon shirt
gray Blazer and Witnesses have said he
has trouble fitting lettuce in his mouth
okay where are you apparently has the
world's smallest penis and doesn't know
how to use it hi there I'm Jake Peralta
Amy's boss that's not true what are you
doing here I am here on a date who is
now leaving worth it have a great night
your boss seems really nice he's not my
boss yes I am I'm here I'm here I'm here
you can start the meeting now the
meeting is over you're late you missed
roll call and the tutorial on using the
new copier six years and no matter how
hard I try I still can't get you to
understand The Importance of Being
punctual maybe you should just give up
and accept me for who I am no I will
break you right now while you were out
being tardy I was hard at work devising
a special punishment I've crafted an
intricate personal high five with
everyone in this office except you what
but you hate high fives yes every minute
of it was hell but it'll be worse for
you Squad dismissed goodbye DS
salute into a fairly wagonal
Snake Charmer goodbye Jeffers
that's the butt butt goodbye Santiago
double fist bump reverse explosion into
a piano strum
all right that was terrible but it's
over now and I made it through goodbye
Leonard from Xerox what no no
you're not giving us any new cases
there's nothing to work on
damn it so this is how it ends well
every ending is a new beginning another
great Gina linetti entrance you better
Savor these while you still can Sarge
Gina I am not in the mood how are you so
unaffected by all this because I have
already moved on I'm devoting my energy
to my new project Gina's on it's a
One-Stop online portal for my Legions of
followers speaking of Hume what's up G
Hive it's Queen G I'm bored at work so
I'm gonna prank all my co-workers that
sounds like a bad idea for an already
crappy day fine Sarge I won't do it
I will do it so you can count this as my
first prank I guess on a fish hey can I
talk to the captain uh he's on the phone
do you want a coffee while you wait they
made me an extra one on accident oh
sure thank you
oh my God what is that man you just
drank cement guys check back in to see
if she dies oh you're not really gonna
die probably okay just a little honey
for the g-hive also you can talk to hold
he is not on the phone what is happening
that's a little something my call two
pranks for the price
[Applause]
Santiago I'm on the phone
search I got a case for you guy that's
phone stolen at a bar last night all
right it's not that big a deal I just
need to file a police report for my
insurance company no it is a major
Injustice and we're gonna set it right
there's a crappy old phone I'd rather
just get a new one we're the police and
we're here to help you so shut your damn
mouth now tell us what he looked like I
only saw his back uh he had a blue
hoodie on whoa we gotta leave
[Music]
you just drank cement
you just drank cement it's over
yes I agree
up down separation
girl you look so sad you know it would
cheer you up nice bowl of miso soup
no thanks Gina I'm not in the mood so
Gina is that soup up for grabs Scully no
my followers are sick of watching you
eat cement the precinct will not be shut
down they decided to shut down the 7-4
instead wait I don't understand
apparently the community came to our a
there was a swell of online support
orchestrated by an organization called
gynazone I think you mean genozon
I was behind the bar the whole time
another great Gina linetti entrance I
told you you can't be back here and I
told you I already am what did you do I
was live streaming a prank when Captain
Holt made his big speech about how you
did the right thing for the city I guess
people were moved they were like what
can we do to help and I said call the
Commissioner's Office the G Hive is real
I can't believe you did it Gina you're a
legend to the nine nine nine
see me
have a nice weekend for Walter yeah
nothing special yeah you missed scully's
birthday
it's kind of a big one
nobody showed at the party guys guys
guys we missed scully's birthday and it
was a big one I know I
take my mom to get birth control pills
that's better than my excuse I said I
had to go to My Girls by mistress Squad
we missed Callie's birthday and it was a
big one I told them I was in Ecuador I
think they bought it we got to make it
up to him let's give him cash everyone
put in 20 each uh yes I'll cover you
it's going huh
we're sorry that we missed your party oh
don't worry about it you all had stuff
to do yes the capital of Ecuador is
Quito
oh anyway
happy birthday from all of us thanks
guys you're the best
I can't believe it the fake birthday
worked
you're a genius we're both geniuses
thumb Jack that was my thumb check guys
I have a great idea for a prank before
Holt comes in I'm gonna put ink on the
podium where he puts his hands I don't
think he'll fall for that I did how I
haven't even opened this yet I guess
it's unrelated Captain Holden hates
pranks this is gonna backfire man ugh
fine I'll tone it down I'll move his
Podium a foot to the left what he'll be
so angry okay five inches five three
three one one all right I'll move it a
half inch fine it's your funeral
worst prank ever so stupid Holt's not
even gonna notice good morning
you guys it
the podium
[Laughter]
you're crazy how did you pull this off